good afternoon to you all and thank you
very much
bipsa for um this opportunity
oh it's a shame i can't see the faces of
the people i'm
talking to but i'm sure most of you know
me
i work at the norwich memorial institute
for medical research
um
yeah so i've been away because
um of covered i'm working virtually and
i'm currently in the u.s but
still actively working so i'm not um
a staff of fine bio but i found
the group online as i explored
what to do with my sequence data
apart from just um understanding
variance in the sequence i wanted to
explore a bit more
about sequence data so i went online and
found this group and i decided to enroll
in one of their courses
i think it was data science
data science and i think it was just a
10 session
program but i was so excited about the
way
they were able to quickly transform
somebody like me with very little
computational skills
into analyzing data
and so i decided to stay on and take on
a project so basically
i decided to work on um
covert because it is the main
issue on board so
together with another colleague we
worked on
how certain drugs that have been
repurposed
for covet treatment work
we know that covered 19
has plagued the world and there's
very little information or drugs
available i think
currently there's only one drug that is
available when there's severe
and there are other drugs that are being
repurposed
one of such drugs is resolutely which
is known to inhibit the juxta
um pathway which is a signaling pathway
that is involved in um
immune responses
and also replication of the virus
differentiation of the virus and
the death of the host cells so
any drug that will
inhibit this pathway is also going to
block the downstream activities of the
pathway
and zolutinib is known to inhibit the
jack stack pathway
so our project was to use resolution
as a standard drag
whose pathway is known or its mechanism
of action is known
and how it will act as an
anti-inhibitory
drug for um
as an anti-inflammatory drug for cover
treatment
so ours was to take another drug
and this drug um was a calcium
blocker i'm not a pain to see how
such a calcium blocker may act to
also prevent um severe curvature
and cover diseases so
what we did was to take um
cell lines treated with
the virus and cell lines treated with
the virus
and these two different drugs and we had
data from um
gene expression from these treated cell
lines
and the analysis we did was to look at
differential expression between these
different groups so
cell lines treated with just a virus and
then cell lines treated with
amlodipine and cell lines treated with
um
resolution to see differential gene
expression between these two
three groups and also to look at
pathways that were enriched as a result
of differential expression between these
um groups so
what we found in the nutshell is that
um amlodipine which is a calcium blocker
is also able to inhibit the juxta
pathway just like resolutions
so there was um genes that were
differentially
expressed and these genes
inhibited or enriched certain pathways
and for resolution or amlodipine treated
cell lines there were down regulation
of these genes in their rich pathways so
basically
sas or the virus is
enriching these pathways by
upregulating certain genes and these
drugs are inhibiting um
the pathways by downregulating certain
genes so
for a calcium blocker like i'm not
depend
we're able to determine how
it may be acting to reduce
the effect of covered infection
and of course there were other um
pathways that were either upregulated or
down regulated but
this was the main finding of our study
and what excited me the most as the way
i was able to quickly um
look at the expression table and then do
analysis such as
dimension reduction using pca or
principal component analysis
looking at normalization of my data
quickly
and then passing it through um
analysis or algorithms like the
this seek or desect for um
expression level or differential gene
expression
and further doing the gene ontology to
look at pathways that were
enriched for somebody with very little
knowledge of um programming or
coding and so
i think that um the group is here they
will tell you more about
how these pathways work or how their
platform works so let me hand you over
to
elia the ceo of pine biotech to
do the rest of the